πουμπορεί να διαφωνούν πλέον και τα λοιπά θεμαδικόν τους επελεξαν τότι ν να κάμουν ο
δημοκραιώς τη θαγμόςση τα σχέσιμο μοκραιός τις αγερμός κα ζητε δικές του θέσεις τδικήν του
μπορείααν με απασχολεί αν αυτό το πράγμα νενα έχει διάρωες βεβαίω στα χείδιάρως προβάμετονώ ότιοφόριδπυ
βεβαία ωσ θα έχει διάρροές αλλέ στο χέρι μας αν εξηγήσουμε να πλά θέσεις μας
εκεί που τ εξηγούμε και επιμείνουμε διότι καμια φορα θέλει και επιμονή να πείς κάτι
το οποίο έλει λήμπαραπάνω εξήγηση ι ο ποια δποτελύση έφερε την κύπρο εδώ που την
έφερεν σε ένα πολύ καλώς σημείω σε σχέση μέτωπου εξεκινήσαμε πριν πάρα πολλά χρόνιά θέλει
επεξήγηση θέλει επεξηγήση πώς γιατί υκαταρχεί για για να κατακαταλίξεις είναι διαφορά είναι δι αφορά
του πολιτικής ως οληση που την πολιτική ως πολιτίε τα πολιδ βλέπουμε ταως γίνονται σύτήματα
και λίω σέσθημα και τα λοιπά και τα λιπά πολύσει όμως τη να πον να
κάτσι απείς πώς λίο το πρόβλημα τδ θέλει λογική αυτή η λογική δπρέπει να την
εξιαστούμ πρέπει να την εξηγάς στο βαθμό που μπορείς και ι και το σύγουρο που
πρέα κάνεισε να μάνο αναλάβεις να την κάνεις διεθεί έχει συμπασία και αυτό εγώ θεωρο
ότιαυτή τη στηαι υπάρχουν διάρρωές και θα υπάρχουν διάρρωες αλλά το σέρι μας να εξηηγήσουμε
γιατί του τ πρόταση ε σύθημα και είναι σ απότελεςα και μπορεί να απότέλεςμαστο μεταμαστευτικό
είχαμε κάτι δηλώσεις του τι που από τοσυγκεκρι πω συγκεκριμένα κόμ πος συγκεκριμε όκομε καδηλώσι
του τύπου να τους δώσουμε διαβατήρια να ς πετάξουμε στη θάλας νείναιείτώρα έσει κάποιο ρεαλίστικά
άνθρωπο πο ου επιστεύκιο δ μπορούν να γίνουν